>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good afternoon,
and welcome to the African
Middle East Division
of the Library of Congress.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb I'm
the chief of the division
and I'm delighted to
see you all here.
I always do a little spiel before
which is I talk about, our division
and I do so because
we're also recorded.
So it's important.
As you know, many of you know
we're made up of three sections,
there's the African, the Hebraic
and the Near East sections.
And we're responsible for 78
countries from around the world,
extending from the whole
Near East, Central Asia,
the [inaudible] the whole content
of Africa and North and Sub Sahara.
And we go up sometimes
even up to China,
deal with some communities there.
And of course we collect,
material from all over the world.
So, we are also very active
in developing collections
in greeting visitors coming from
all the countries that I mentioned
and the different regions.
We organize programs,
symposia, workshops,
we also organize exhibits.
And in 2012, for example we
celebrated 100 years of Hebraic here
at the library, with a
wonderful exhibit entitled Words
Like Sapphires, 100 years of
Hebraica at the Library of Congress.
And then many of you know
Peggy Pearlstein [phonetic],
she used to be the head of the
Hebraica section, and Sharon,
and Brenner, and many
others were involved
in putting the exhibit together.
We also invite scholars and experts
who have researched and done work
in areas of responsibility to
share with us their thoughts,
their research, their findings.
So that we come out enriched
from, the proceedings.
And we celebrate heritage month.
In February it's Black
History month,
in March it's Norooz,
the Persian New year.
And in May we always celebrate
Jewish-American heritage month.
So I wish to thank the
Jewish Genealogy Society
of Greater Washington and
the Jewish Historical Society
of Greater Washington
for partnering with us
in the celebration at the library.
And not only this year,
but for several years past.
Today's program with Dr. Janette
Silverman, who is a past resident
of the Jewish Genealogy Society,
will address a historical issue.
She will be talking about
one of her projects,
that focuses on the family
history of the Blumenthals
of the Upper Lower
Peninsula of Michigan.
And now to introduce the program
and the speaker is our
own Sharon Horowitz,
a senior reference librarian
in the Hebraic section
of the African Middle East Division.
Sharon.
>> Sharon Horowitz:
Thank you, Mary-Jane.
Good afternoon welcome
to the African
and Middle Eastern reading room.
On behalf of the Jewish Genealogy
Society of Greater Washington
and the Jewish Historical
Society of Greater Washington,
and the Hebraic section,
let me thank you all
for coming to today's program.
In celebration of Jewish-American
heritage month.
As you heard, I'm Sharon Horowitz,
I'm a reference librarian
in the Hebraic section.
The Hebraic section marks its
beginnings in 1912 with the receipt
of 10,000 Hebrew books and pamphlets
whose purchase was made possible
by a gift from New York
Philanthropist, Jacob Schiff.
From those humble beginning
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items in Hebrew
Yiddish Ladino, Judeo-Persian
and other Hebraic script languages.
And our holdings also include
an important collection
of [inaudible]books.
The sections holdings are
particularly strong in the areas
of Bible [inaudible] liturgy,
Hebrew language and literature,
responsa and Jewish history.
Two of our missions in this division
are to publicize our collections
and to bring people
into the library.
And one way we do that is by
holding lectures and having programs
such as the one we are
hosting here today.
Before I introduce today's
speaker, it is my pleasure
to call upon Dr. Eugene Alpert,
president of the Jewish Genealogy
Society of Greater Washington.
And one of today's
programs co-sponsors
to say a few words
about the society.
[ Applause ]
>> Eugene Alpert: Thank
you, Sharon it's my pleasure
to be here this afternoon.
And I'm going to speak
very briefly let you know
that the Jewish Genealogy Society
of Greater Washington is composed
of about 250 members, and
we were founded in 1980.
Our mission is to,
discover, document,
and share the family history of
people who have Jewish backgrounds.
And we meet about 10 months a year,
in fact Janette was giving
a presentation yesterday
on the Ukrainian special interest
group of Jewish Gen. And I want
to welcome you all here this
afternoon, if you're interested
in joining and learning
more about the association,
I've got some brochures
on the back table there.
So thank you again, all for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Sharon Horowitz: Thank
you very much Dr. Alpert
and now a word about our speaker.
Dr. Silverman has been involved
in Jewish genealogical
research for 35 years.
Currently, she is a senior
genealogist, research manager
and ancestry pro genealogist.
Previously she has worked in
Jewish education, published widely
in genealogy and been a frequent
speaker at conferences and meetings
in the United States and Israel
speaking on such topics as,
personalizing Jewish
history using archival
and digital databases for research.
Ellis Island mythology and using
mobile books and [inaudible]
as genealogical resources.
Dr. Silverman is the co-chair
of the IAJGS Conference being
held in August in Seattle.
She has suggested that her
love of genealogy has its roots
in her father's love
of history and Judaism
and her mother's love
of jigsaw puzzles.
Her presentation today will
discuss methodology and resources
for doing genealogical research.
She will be sharing her own
family research as a case study.
Before I turn the podium
over, however, I must mention
that this event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal question
and answer period after the lecture
at which the audience is encouraged
to ask questions and offer comments.
Please be advised, that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the question
and answer period you are consenting
to the library's possible
reproduction
and transmission of your remarks.
And now, please join me in
welcoming Dr. Janette Silverman.
[ Applause ]
>> Janette Silverman:
Thank you, everyone.
I'm absolutely thrilled
and delighted
to have been asked here today
and to be standing before you
in such an amazing space.
I hope you'll forgive a brief
introduction written on a napkin
that I figure dif Lincoln could get
away writing the Gettysburg Address
on an envelope, although this
isn't anywhere near as erudite,
it's a napkin from the cafeteria
at the [inaudible] office.
In the brief time I have
available today, I plan to share
with you the example, of
one northern Michigan family
as an illustration of
the methods and sources
of historical genealogical research
and the micro stories
that it produces.
As Sharon indicated, whoops,
sorry, as Sharon indicated,
my talk today is about my
own personal family history.
A question about advancing
the slides,
is it just on the, is
it on the computer?
Oh, okay, great, thank you.
So I should preface by
comments by saying to you,
that I ask more questions
than I answer.
Some of this is going to be
due to the lack of time today,
but mostly it's because I
haven't found the answers yet.
As in many genealogical research
projects, for each tidbit
of information that's discovered
two or more questions arise.
In the course of this research I
utilized many different resources,
I visited the Michigan
State Library in Lansing
and a local library in Standish.
I spoke on the phone and
via email with volunteers
at the West Branch Ogemaw County,
Michigan Historical Society
and the Au-Gres Historical
Society in Arenac County.
And I visited countless archival
resources on the internet.
As every genealogist knows, when
there's a branch of the family
about which little
or nothing is known
that absolutely must be researched
nature abhors a vacuum a genealogist
of a course an empty leaf on a tree.
In this case, the space was a branch
on the tree belonging the family
of my partner, Robert Clinton.
And the appropriate place of
course to start, as we all know,
is by interviewing family.
So my starting point was Robert's
mother, Phyllis Blumenthal
who was born and lived most of
her life actually all of her life,
sorry, in the Detroit area.
As the oldest living person
on her side of the family,
I was hoping that she
knew family stories.
I began the research project
in 2005 by asking her questions
about her father Isadore Blumenthal.
He died in 1976, I was hoping
that she would know
something about his family.
When I asked her, she said
the family was estranged.
That's not very helpful is it?
So I started with a few facts
that Phyllis could provide.
Phyllis was born in 1924 in Detroit,
her father Isadore was born in 1895
in Standish, Arenac
county, Michigan.
The family was German
and they owned a store.
Isadore's father's name was
Samuel and his mother was Dorah,
and Isadore had two
siblings, Hannah and Albert.
Not an awful lot of information,
but at least a local
and a couple of names.
In years gone by, without archival
resources on the internet and ways
to find and connect with people,
resolving this would have
been almost impossible,
certainly without having people
on the ground in Michigan
who could look through
the resources there.
But today, research
is much different.
And yet sometimes it's
still necessary to get away
from the computer and
pay a personal visit.
I was able to visit the cemetery
where Phyllis' grandparents
Samuel and Dorah, were buried.
Although photos of gravestones
are sometimes available,
through digital resources, how many
of you have used digital
resources to look at gravestones?
So you know what I'm talking about,
you know that there's
some great resources
out there including Joe Bar
the Jewish Gen online worldwide
burial records.
Find a grave, Jewish
data.com and other resources.
But I like, when I can
to visit a cemetery.
I encourage everybody
that can do that, to do it
and to take photographs
while you're there.
If you can't of course, the next
best thing is a photo online or one
that the cemetery can send you.
Some cemeteries will respond to a
phone call by sending you a photo,
some require a letter, a written
letter along with payment,
generally under $25 to
send you a photograph.
To take and send the photograph.
Now the Hebrew on the stones,
sometimes can give you some
interesting information.
The Hebrew on these stones
includes the names of the deceased
and their father's
names, typical things
to find on a Jewish tombstone.
This also includes their
death dates, the English,
the Arabic numeral that you
see on the gravestones are only
of the year of their deaths.
But the Hebrew gives us the
date of their deaths too.
Now, sometimes the Hebrew dates are
off by a day from the English dates,
has anybody encountered that?
The, if the Hebrew data is off by a
day from the English date it means
that they died after dark,
on that English date.
So that sometimes gives you a
useful piece of family history,
something else to fill in the blanks
about how your ancestors
lived or died.
In one case I found a tombstone
whose English date was 11 months off
from the Hebrew date,
different year,
different month, different date.
Turned out, that the stone cutters
had cut the date of the unveiling
of the stone in the English date.
And the Hebrew date was
the correct date of death.
I only found that out
by doing some research,
pulling a death certificate,
checking on the Steve Morse website.
Is everybody familiar with
the Steve Morse website?
Steve Morse has a phenomenal
website that, links you to,
it's called One-Step and
it links you to things
like Ellis Island and
other ship manifest.
But for this purpose, what it
does is it gives you a translation
between Gregorian and Julian dates,
between Hebrew and Gregorian dates.
And it's a wonderful
resource, check it out.
If you just Google Steve Morse
you'll get there eventually.
Now, we often think that the people
that we're researching
have unique names.
But chances are there were other
people living in that same place
at that same time that
shared their names.
So the information
on the gravestones
becomes even more important
with the addition of
the father's name.
You can often put together
an entire generation
because you know the father's
name and this comes into play
in a little while when I, tell you
about people with the same sir names
that we, whose relationship we
needed to be able to determine.
Now when I began my research, I
attacked the questions by visiting,
first the state library in
Lansing using databases online,
Googling people and
places on the internet,
making several phone calls,
and working with individuals
through exchanges of
information via email.
And my questions at the
beginning were really basic,
where was Standish, Michigan?
I had absolutely no idea.
I'm a New Yorker, what do
I know about the Midwest?
What kind of store did they have?
How and when did they get
from Standish to Detroit?
And were there other
relatives in Standish?
More questions arose
as I began my research.
But these were just
the beginning ones.
I'm not going to walk you
through my research step by step
because it would not
only be tedious for you
but it would probably take just as
long for me to do that as it did
for me to do the research.
But I am going to tell you
the story of the Blumenthals,
or at least as much of
it as I've found to date.
There's still much left to
be discovered and in fact,
now that I think about it, I
realized how little I actually know.
I'm not beginning at the beginning,
because that would be beyond
the scope of this discussion
but rather I'm going to start with a
brief mention that in 1881 the first
of three Blumenthal
brothers left Europe.
Their names were Bernard,
Phillip, and Samuel.
Now remember I said the
family was from Germany,
how many of your families
came from Germany, anybody?
Do you know where in
Germany they came from?
>> [Inaudible response]
>> Janette.
Silverman: In Berlin.
>> [Inaudible response].
>> Janette Silverman: Berlin
and Pomerania, anybody else?
You know I didn't know
anything about German research.
I still don't know.
Because these people
weren't from Germany.
That caused me pause, and I needed
to regroup and figure this out.
It seems that the Blumenthal
family was from Courland.
Not Lativa, not Germany.
Courland was originally settled
by German knights although it
was never owned by Germany.
But the inhabitants thought
of themselves as German.
Not documented was the
arrival of the oldest
of the three brothers Bernard
in 1881 at the age of 20.
He very likely sailed
into New York harbor
but no evidence has been
found yet to prove that.
And frankly, I hate
having these kinds of gaps,
those of you who know me
know that I really hate this.
But there's nothing to be done
about it except to keep researching.
Those of you who are engaged in any
sort of genealogical research know
that this passion becomes
an obsession.
And is never ending.
Ship manifest often have lots of
wonderful information on them,
but some of the early manifests
only had lists of names.
So it's really impossible
to figure out if the people
that you're looking up are
really the people you want
to be looking up.
Because it's only a name,
sometimes it's an age,
it may have a generic country but
not any more information than that.
Later, ship manifests will give
you, oh the name and address
of the person and the
country that they left.
The name and address of the person
they're destined to be going to,
their occupation, and
other useful information
but not the earlier ones.
And there are many, many resources
online that can provide images
of ships and details
about specific sailings.
You can get there looking
at the Steve Morse website,
you can get there on
the ship's list.com
and libertyellisfoundation.org,
olive tree genealogy
and of course the National Archives
and Records of Administration, NARA.
Now, our documented story begins
in July 1882 with the arrival
in New York of the
youngest of the brothers,
17 year-old Samuel Blumenthal
on board the SS Cimbria.
No evidence has been found to date
of whether Samuel joined Bernard
in New York or went to join
him, out west or if he remained
in New York waiting for the arrival
of the third brother, Phillip.
In 1883 Phillip Blumenthal arrived
in New York onboard the SS Grecian
Monarch departing from London.
He was 23 years old, and like
Samuel, his occupation was listed
on the ship manifest as laborer.
You can see that his country
of origin was noted as Germany,
that would be this column there.
Now Bernard started out in
Traverse City, Michigan,
and I've circled Traverse City in
green for those of you who like me,
have no frame of reference
with Michigan.
And his brothers probably
joined him there, but again,
I don't know that piece
of information.
The lumber industry was
in full swing in the 1800s
and there were supplies of
all sorts that were needed.
In Traverse City, the brothers may
have been supplying the lumbermen
with equipment.
One of the really phenomenal
things available
through the internet is access to
digital archives and the ability
to search them in the
blink of an eye.
The Library of Congress, this
institution has an amazing store
of historical photographs
among many other things.
And this is from the
Library of Congress archives.
Now from 1881 until 1885
the brothers worked in
and around the Traverse City area,
by 1885 they had left Traverse City
and settled in West Branch.
That was a distance of about 90
miles, probably several days journey
in the 1880s by horseback
or horse and carriage.
They may have visited there
as their territory expanded
and noticed business
opportunities in a growing town.
Other than that I have
no idea why they went
from Traverse City to West Branch.
Hopefully one of these
days I'll find
that missing piece of information.
According to records from the
West Branch Ogemaw County,
Michigan Historical Society,
Bernard opened a dry
goods store there in 1885.
And this is his first
store, the New York store.
By 1887 either that store
had closed or been renamed,
or Phillip had opened his
own store, the Chicago store.
They're working their
way around the country.
In 1890, Bernard Blumenthal married
Sophia Frank in Ogemaw County,
marriage records are wonderful
sources of information,
it gives names of the parents
of the bride and groom.
It gives you an idea of where
they might have been living,
a little snapshot in time.
By 1892 a second Blumenthal
family was living
on the lower peninsula, in Standish.
Standish and West Branch are
both within that large circle,
and it's slightly less than
30 miles from West Branch.
Probably a day's journey by horse.
Marcus Blumenthal, this was the
family that was now in Standish.
Marcus Blumenthal and his
family survived a fire in 1892
as reported in the local newspaper.
Although most of the local
newspapers I used are not available
through digital searches,
online, I was able to get a number
of items through gen web links.
And a wonderful archivist
in Arenac County,
who sent me many, many
items by email.
Many of the online archives
have different selections
of newspaper collections
including genealogy bank,
the archives belonging
to individual newspapers,
newspapers.com and
fultonhistory.com.
When you're looking for newspaper
articles about a particular place
or a time, you, just like
other searches, you don't want
to restrict yourself
to just one resource.
You want to use as many
as you've got access to,
because they all have
slightly different things.
And the searches are different on
each of the websites that you go to.
So you might come up with different
results even though say two
different archives have
the same newspapers,
because of the way the searches are
configured you might have different
results by the end.
In August, 1894 Samuel
Blumenthal identified
on this marriage record
as both Solomon and Sam.
Married Dorah Gordon in New York.
Samuel was born in Courland,
I see this on his marriage
record, right here.
His parents were Israel
and Hannah Gordon,
their names are also on here.
And he resided in West
Branch, Michigan.
Now Hannah's parents
were Adolph Gordon
and Hannah Drakman [phonetic],
and she too was born in Courland
but was residing n New York.
Now other documents about
Hannah, about Dorah,
indicated that she might
have been born in New York,
I've never found proof of her birth
in either Courland or New York.
So it's just one of those
other mysteries still waiting
to be resolved.
I also haven't found
any information to prove
or disprove whether her
father Adolph Gordon,
and Samuel's mother Hannah
Gordon, were related.
But like many other
European Jewish families,
they likely could have been.
Jewish families have a habit of
marrying within the families,
first and second cousin
marriages are very typical
within different areas.
Chances are that some of
you may be missing a pair
of great grandparents,
because of cousin marriages.
Something that's very
typical when you're looking
through Jewish genealogical
resources to find
that you can't find one set of great
grandparents and then you discover
that you were just looking in the
wrong place because they were there.
But they were hidden because
of their other relationships
to each other.
Copies of New York City, records,
vital records such as this marriage
record are available primarily
in two places the New York
City Municipal Archives
on Chambers Street, and
through the microfilm collection
at the Family History
Library in Salt Lake City.
But there are indexes to these that
are available in many other places,
including familysearch.org
and ancestry.com.
Now after their marriage in New
York, Dorah and Samuel returned
to West Branch at least
for a short while.
By October 1895, on the same page
in Standish, remember they were
in West Branch now
they're in Standish.
This page records the
birth of Israel Blumenthal
who later changes his
name to Isadore.
You can see the date here in 1940
when that change was made official.
And just a couple of lines above
that, is Stella Blumenthal.
Stella's Marcus' daughter,
we read about the fire,
with Marcus Blumenthal's
family, Stella's his daughter.
Some of the unanswered questions
are why did they, why did Samuel
and Dorah move to Standish?
And what was the relationship
between Stella Blumenthal's
parents and Isadore's parents?
The 1897 Michigan Business
Directory lists two Blumenthals
with dry goods stores in Standish.
Harry and Samuel, who's Harry?
Who's Marcus with a general store?
I mean it's the same
Marcus that we saw
in the other records but who is he?
To date, many documents
referring to both Harry
and Marcus have been located but
in none of them is there any way
to establish a familiar
relationship between them.
Or for that matter,
between them and Isadore.
Now as an aside, Marcus was not
a brother of Bernard, Phillip,
and Samuel, they're
father was Israel
and Marcus' father
was Hyam [phonetic].
One of the many documents I haven't
found to date, and there's a lot
of documents I haven't found.
Is the marriage record of
Phillip Blumenthal and Sara Hill.
Who by 1892, when their
daughter is Estella who is born,
were already married,
and this is a 1900 census
from West Branch Village,
Ogemaw County.
Phillip Blumenthal and his family
and that gave me the information
about how old their daughter was.
So when the likelihood
was of their marriage,
sometime before she
was born, probably.
The 1900 census also shows
Samuel and his family,
they were living in Standish.
And the U.S. Census is
available through many websites,
some of them are free, some of
them are subscription based.
And each of the archival collections
is searchable through an index based
on transcriptions of the data that's
included in the original document.
Some of the transcriptions
vary in the type
of information that's
extracted from the census.
Since these resources do
their own transcriptions
or have their own unique algorithms
for searching, you often have
to do searches in multiple
resources.
So if you're looking for a
census record in one resource
and you don't find it, go look
for it in another resource.
Sooner or later you're bound to
find it, through an index or,
if you don't find it through
an index, go look page by page,
find the ED, the enumeration
districts
through Steve Morse's website
where he's got a handy
little tool to figure it out.
And go page by page.
It may be tedious, but it's
definitely worth it and sometimes
when you're going page by
page, you'll find things
that you didn't even think of
finding, like other relatives.
Meanwhile back in West Branch, the
store went through several changes
and in the early 1900s became
Blumenthal and Company.
This picture of the Blumenthal store
as well as the earlier pictures are
from the Ogemaw County
Historical Society's archive.
Remember I said that for every
answer there were a couple more
questions, well, in October
1905 newspaper reported
that cousin Helen Blumenthal from
Chicago was visiting the family.
Now remember one of the earlier
stores was called the Chicago Store,
maybe that was acknowledging
the existence
of a family in Chicago, maybe not.
But, who was she?
The only Helen Blumenthal I've
been able to find and connect
to the family was born in 1896
and she was Bernard's daughter.
She certainly wasn't visiting
from Chicago by 1905 when the rest
of her family was still
living in West Branch.
I don't know who she was.
Like I said, it's a
never ending project.
As verified by an August
1906 society note
in the Arenac newspaper, the
Standish Blumenthals, that's Samuel
and Dorah and the West
Branch Blumenthals,
Samuel's brothers Bernard
and Phillip stayed in touch.
A 1909 photo from the historical
society archives shows Bernard,
his wife Sophia, and their children.
I love this picture.
It doesn't look like any of
my other family pictures.
I'm always saying that we all
have the same set of pictures,
maybe with just different
faces overlaying them.
But they all look the
same, this doesn't look
like any other picture I have.
So maybe there's actually
two pictures floating around,
not just the one that I thought.
On the 1910 census, living in
Standish we find Samuel, Dorah,
and their three children
Isadore, Hannah, and Adolph.
And just three doors away
we see Harry Blumenthal
who we first encountered in
the 1897 business directory,
and an Adolph Blumenthal.
Both of them are boarders.
Harry was 39 years old and
Adolph was 29 years old,
and they were born in Russia.
They were probably born in Russia,
the same way that the other
Blumenthals were born in Germany.
I think that they were
all really from Courland,
which may have been
considered part of Germany
because it was settled that way.
It certainly had more right to
be considered part of Russia
because I think it probably was, at
least for a brief period of time,
part of the Russian Empire.
Now by 1912 Sam and
Harry Blumenthal,
had established a dry
goods store together.
Remember the question, who's Harry?
I still don't have an answer for it.
I just have the question.
But now they're in
business together.
One of the delights
in doing this sort
of research is locating
oddities this is
about the oddest thing
I've ever found.
It's a 1912 English
sparrow certificate issued
to Adolph Blumenthal,
now I don't know
if the Adolph is the
Adolph living with Harry
or the Adolph who was Samuel's son.
But there was a bounty for killing
two pests, sparrows and rats.
And this is Adolph's
certificate, he's entitled,
it looks like 92 cents for his
46 sparrows, 2 cents a sparrow.
And delivered, they
weren't just taking his word
for it, can you imagine?
Going around killing
them, collecting them,
and then bringing them, I wonder
if they were stored in the ice box.
Now, by 1919 Isadore
was living in Detroit.
This is evidenced by his marriage
to Minnie Stein [phonetic].
They lived in the Detroit metro
area the rest of their lives.
They had two daughters,
Elaine and Phyllis.
Elaine had no children,
Phyllis had three children.
And Isadore died, as I said earlier,
in 1976 after a long illness.
His daughters, well growing
up didn't spend much time
with their West Branch cousins,
although Phyllis had
some recollections
of Martin, Phillip's son.
She didn't remember the names
of any of the other people,
that were living in West Branch.
She didn't even realize that
there were people living
in West Branch who
were related to her.
It's not clear when Samuel
and Dorah moved to Detroit,
but by 1920 that's
where the family was.
Now, Detroit, all the way down
here, is 140 miles from Standish
and 160 miles from West Branch.
It's a really long, drive,
possibly trains ran back and forth.
But however the transportation
method was, at that point,
the families up in the
peninsula and the family
in Detroit certainly
weren't spending a great deal
of time together.
Now Phillip and his family stayed
in West Branch, as did Bernard
and his family, and there's the 1920
census with both of the families
and their children on there.
The children of the three
brothers did not all remain
in Michigan through time.
Samuel's three children
stayed in the Detroit area.
This is the original family
group, so we've got Israel
and Hannah Gordon back in Courland,
and their three sons Phillip,
Bernard, and Samuel and their wives.
Bernard had married early,
he married a woman named
Anna Grabowski [phonetic],
who probably died, and then
he remarried Sophia Frank.
And we looked at information
about Sophia and Bernard earlier.
And Phillip, as I'd
said, married Sara Hill.
These are the descendents of each
of the families, many of whom stayed
in Detroit but others left.
So Phillip's daughter,
Dorothy, and her husband Albert,
settled in West Chester
county, New York by 1927.
In 1930 it was clear
that Dorothy's brother,
Isadore was living with
Dorothy and Albert.
And, as far as I knew, Isadore
never married, or so I thought.
As I was preparing for today's talk,
all of the research
is ever changeable.
There's stuff coming in from
the most unexpected places.
So I'm preparing this talk,
I thought I was done,
and I got an email.
And the email identified the writer
as a descendant of, an
Ira Mark Blumenthal.
Ira Mark Blumenthal, son of Phillip.
Well I know who all of
Phillip's children were.
Who's Ira mark Blumenthal?
The only person he could possibly
be is Isadore who I lost track
of after the 1930 census.
He stayed in New York,
he became Ira Mark.
Now I need to do a little more
research to fill in the blanks.
I know that Martin never married,
I know that Hazel married
this guy Monty.
I know that Estella married Arthur,
and these were their children.
But I didn't have any
information about Isadore.
Now I need to go back and
find Ira Mark, not Isadore.
To do that I'll look in the
1940 census, I'll take a look
at some city directories
and some phone books.
Since I know from this relative of
his that he was living in New York,
I'll also try checking out
New York City marriage records
and maybe even some death records.
And see what I can find.
There's got to be something,
everybody leaves a trace,
it's just how difficult it
is to find those traces,
those shadows of people's lives.
Now, this is Bernard's family
and Bernard's daughter Della,
and her husband John Jacob Rueben
[phonetic]left Michigan shortly
after their 1918 marriage
and settled in Toledo, Ohio.
The rest of Phillip's and Bernard's
children stayed in Michigan.
Hannah married Yale Roberts and as
far as I know they had no children.
But I guess if I can find
that there was something more
to Isadore maybe there's something
else that I haven't uncovered
about Hannah and Yale although,
I think I know, who knows.
Anything is possible.
Adolph who also was named, was known
as Albert, so we've got Israel known
as Isadore, and Isadore
known as Ira,
and now an Adolph known as Albert.
He married Reuben in 1923 and they
also stayed in the Detroit area,
they ultimately had two
daughters Ada Ruth and Joyce.
Ada has three sons and they
no longer live in Michigan,
they're family's settled in North
Carolina, Florida, and Arizona.
And Joyce lives in
Canada and has one son.
During the course of this research,
I met an awful lot of relatives
that nobody in the part of the
Blumenthal family that I knew,
knew of, including when I
did a talk about the family
up in the West Branch Ogemaw County
Historical Society two years ago.
We had met, I had met, via email,
another one of the descendants,
a grandchild or a great
grandchild of one of the,
of either Phillip or Bernard.
I forget which now, and
he came to that talk.
And so at that talk I was
able to introduce two cousins,
who had never heard of
each other before that day.
It's one of the more
exciting things that happens
as you're doing research.
How many of you have
wound up meeting relatives
that you'd never heard of before,
never imagined through the research?
Isn't it great?
I've found, over the years that
although I used to get, unbelievably
and amazingly excited when I found
my own relatives and I still do.
I get just as exited if I
met other people's relatives.
I'm indiscriminate about how excited
I get doing genealogical research.
So I have a bunch of questions left.
Who was Helen Blumenthal of Chicago?
How are Harry, Marcus, and Adolph
Blumenthal of Standish related
to Samuel, Phillip, and Bernard?
Or even to each other?
I know that Marcus, Harry,
and Adolph are not all
brothers, two of them are.
I could tell that from
gravestones and death records,
but I have no idea what
the relationship is.
I suspect, that if I can ever
figure this out, that I'll find
that their fathers were either
brothers or first cousins,
there's enough names between
the, between the families,
between Marcus' children, Samuel,
Phillip, and Bernard's children.
There's enough names that are the
same or similar to make me think
that they're all being
named after the same people.
I'm making an assumption here,
but perhaps it's not
a, correct assumption.
I'm assuming that everybody knows
about eastern European
naming patterns,
eastern European Jewish
naming patterns.
But I'm seeing a couple of heads
shaking, so eastern European Jews,
as opposed to Sephardic Jews,
rarely name their children
after living relatives.
Children are generally named
after deceased relatives,
and what'll happen is say you've
got children, their parents die,
they've got children
so grandchildren.
And all of a sudden you've
got flurry of kids in a family
that all have the same name.
They're all named after
grandparents who died.
You can track death dates of people
based on naming patterns based on,
children who all of a sudden
are carrying their names.
That helps you identify
when people died
and find additional
family information.
If you don't have birth
dates of people but you know
who they were named after,
you can also sometimes figure
out when they were born which
helps you isolate the resources
that you need to be investigating
as you do more family research.
I also don't yet know how Philip
arrived in the United States,
I'm sorry, how Bernard
arrived in the United States.
I don't know the year he arrived,
I don't know where he came into,
probably New York, but I
don't know that for sure.
I don't know how the brothers
got from New York to Michigan,
if they went in together, or if
they all joined the pioneering
first arrival.
And I don't know why, they
went from New York to Michigan.
All of those things bother me.
Sleepless nights bothering.
Sometimes waking up at 4 o'clock in
the morning with an inspiration of,
I've got to go look for this there.
Running to the computer
and at 4 o'clock
in the morning, doing some research.
Now some of you are smiling or
giggling, you've been there,
you know what I'm talking about.
Genealogist dreams.
So I'd be really remised if I
didn't make some comments about some
of the resources I used during
the course of this project.
In 2005 I sent an email to
the West Branch public library
seeking assistance.
Because in addition
to everything else,
genealogy is very much a networking
effort, someone sent a copy
of my inquiry to Louann
Zetltle [phonetic],
the president at that time, of
the Ogemaw Historical Society.
Who entered into now a decade
long, correspondence with me.
We've talked over the
phone, we've emailed.
And in 2014, 9 years after I
started this, right after a visit
to West Branch where I introduced,
as I said two Blumenthal
descendants to each other.
We visited Standish in Arenac County
and met with Joann Gulo [phonetic]
of Au Gres Michigan and
I apologize to Joann
if I've mispronounced her last name.
And if I've mispronounced
the town, she's a volunteer
at the Standish Historical Society
and in the years since that visit,
she has scanned and emailed me
every document that she found
in the society's archives.
And in the courthouse,
and the newspaper,
that pertain to the
Blumenthal family.
Most of that archive isn't digitized
and although it's really well
organized ,thanks to the efforts
of Joann and other volunteers,
it's not all indexed or digitized.
Of course, online my most common
resources are ancestry.com,
jewishgen.org, family search,
the Library of Congress,
The National Archives, and many
other online archival resources.
All of which paid a big
part in this project as well
as in many other research
projects I'm involved in.
And I thank you all for
letting me do this today.
Pardon, there was some
instructions about asking questions.
Okay, I'll repeat the questions.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Janette Silverman:
Thank you, thank you.
So I just received some
advice that number one,
that my number one question
who is Helen Blumenthal
of Chicago should really go
at the bottom of the list,
because social editors in newspapers
receiving phone calls about visitors
and other items to be put in
often couldn't hear very clearly
on the phones party lines and such.
And they have taken notes, scribbled
notes about the name of a person
who was coming to visit and
where they were coming from.
And may not have been able
to read handwriting correctly
so I might want to just relegate
that, search for Helen Blumenthal
to the bottom of the list and
assume that okay, it was somebody
that was coming to visit
the Blumenthal family.
But maybe [inaudible] from
[inaudible] and leave it at that.
Thank you.
Yes, Gene?
[ Inaudible response ]
>> Janette Silverman: Yeah, so
one of the great resources online
and I'm sorry that I failed to
mention it, the Michigan Jewish,
Historical archives has
digitized all of their journals
and there are a couple of articles
in there about Jews in Traverse City
and I don't remember the exact
number, but there were Jews
in Traverse City back then.
But there is no mention at all in
any of these, in any of the journals
that I read, and I read
through almost all of them
and it's quite an extensive
collection, didn't find any mention
at all of the Blumenthal family.
There was, Traverse
City is on the water,
and barges are coming in and out.
There were a number of stores
that had opened there to be able
to supply lumber workers and
I supposed, also the fur trade
and other, trading goods.
So there was a community of sorts,
I suspect from what I've read
that the Blumenthal brothers
didn't have a store per say there,
but they were peddlers.
And they may have been
picking up goods and going
around to the different camps
and trading there and coming back
to town, perhaps supplying
the stores with some goods,
that they had gotten in
exchange for the goods
that they brought up there.
So.
[ Inaudible response ]
>> Janette Silverman: It is
possible, I have not found that.
I have not found nay
connection there
in the research that I've done.
And I didn't see any similarities
in the names that I was looking
at in Traverse City
and back in Courland.
The resources that I used
for the Courland portion
of this research was from
the, Lativa SIG on Jewish Gen,
the Latvian special interest group
which has done an amazing job
with transcriptions of
records from Courland.
And there's a lot of
information that's online
through Jewish Gen. The Latvian
government had their vital records
revisions lists, conscription
lists and tax records all online
through the Latvian government site.
I'm happy to send any of you
that link, my cards are up front
under the two monitors
if anybody wants
to be able to get in touch with me.
And Christine Ouston [phonetic],
from France who very regretfully
died suddenly a couple of years ago,
has done a phenomenal
transcription of the vital records
from the Latvian archives,
from Courland.
And, those are available,
the indexes of the vital records are
available and she did a great job
in comprehensive transcriptions,
from those.
So the vital records themselves have
very little additional information
that's not on her transcriptions.
The vital records are in, I'm
going to tell you the language
that they're in, and I'm
going to get it wrong.
I think that they're in Russian,
but I won't swear to God.
Don't hold me to that.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Janette Silverman: Oh yeah he,
Isadore came to Detroit ad
retired not, I'm sorry Samuel,
Isadore's father, yeah,
Isadore was quite ill for many,
many years with rheumatoid
arthritis.
And wasn't able to work for
a large portion of his life.
Samuel retired not too long after
arriving in New York, in Detroit,
but they maintained
stores until he retired.
And I understand from
family stories,
that when he retired
he was fairly well off,
had a driver that took him around.
And there's quite a
number of family stories.
>> How many stores in Detroit?
>> Janette Silverman: He had
at least a store in Detroit.
>> [Inaudible response].
>> Janette Silverman: Mmm mm, no.
And I don't think that he
had it for a long while.
There's references to it, to when
he sold the store in Standish,
came to Detroit to retire but
I found some other documents
that indicate that he
had, he was not retired
when he first came to Detroit.
Sitting in the front row is Samuel's
great grandson, Robert Clinton.
And he'll be happy to answer
questions that you might have
about his great grandfather
who died before he was born.
And his grandfather
Isadore who he did know.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Janette Silverman: Yeah,
the family's not related as far
as I know to any Jacobson family.
>> Okay but what I want to know.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Janette Silverman: Yeah,
actually we do we've got their,
we've got gravestones and the
gravestones are really clear
of the father's name and
some other information.
We don't know, I know that two of
them are related to each other,
and the third one is not.
>> Okay.
>> Janette Silverman: Okay.
Yeah, yeah, Harry, Adolph, and
Marcus are probably related.
I assume that they may be cousins.
Two of them are brothers,
one is not.
>> I got the impression
that they were [inaudible].
>> Janette Silverman: Yeah,
no, I know their father's name,
I'm sorry I probably
wasn't that clear.
And they came from Courland
and settled in Michigan
but again I don't know
when they arrived.
I don't know why they
arrived, why the came there.
>> [Inaudible response].
>> No, Marcus, Harry, and
Adolph died in this country.
Their fathers, as well
as Bernard, Philip,
and Samuel's father
never left Europe.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Janette Silverman: Yeah, and
thank you for that Mary-Jane.
Yes, I've looked all over the place,
but I have never found the
arrival information for Bernard
where I found it from his two
brothers, from Samuel and Phillip
within two years of his arrival.
But never found, never
found his ship manifest,
not coming into the U.S.
and not coming into Canada.
But again at those early
arrivals, it's just lists.
And Blumenthal isn't
an uncommon name.
And I don't know what name he
might have been traveling under.
Thank you very much everybody.
>> Sharon Horowitz: Thank you very
much, thank you, and thank you all.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.